[Music]
we see with the eyes but we see with the
brain as well and seeing with the brain
is often called imagination and we are
familiar with the landscapes of our own
imagination our in scapes we've lived
with them all our lives but there are
also hallucinations as well and
hallucinations are completely different
they don't seem to be of our creation
they don't seem to be under control they
seem to come from the outside and to
mimic perception so I'm going to be
talking about hallucinations and a
particular sort of visual hallucination
which I see among my patients a few
months ago I got a phone call from a
nursing home where I work they told me
that one of their residents an old lady
in her 90s was seeing things and they
wondered if she'd gone bonkers or
because she was an old lady whether she
had had a stroke or whether she had
Alzheimer's and so um they asked me if I
would come and see Rosalie
the old lady I went in to see her it was
evident straightaway that she was
perfectly sane and lucid and of good
intelligence but she'd been very
startled and very bewildered book she
been seeing things and she told me the
nurses hadn't mentioned this that she
was blind that she had been completely
blind for macular degeneration for five
years but now for the last few days
she'd been seeing things so I said what
sorts of things and she said people in
Eastern dress and drapes walking up and
down stairs a man who turns towards me
and smiles but he has huge teeth on one
side of his mouth animals too I see a
white building at snowing a soft
no I see this horse with a harness
dragging the snow away then one night
the scene changes I see cats and dogs
walking towards me they come to a
certain point and then stop then it
changes again I see a lot of children
there walking up and down stairs they
wear bright colors rose and blue like
Eastern dress sometimes she said before
the people come on
she may hallucinate pink and blue
squares on the floor which seemed to go
up to the ceiling
so I said is this like a dream and she
said no it's not like a dream it's it's
like a movie she said that Scott color
has got motion but it's completely
silent like a silent movie and she said
it was a rather boring movie she said
all these people with the Eastern dress
walking up and down very very repetitive
very limited
and she she had a sense of humor she
knew it was a hallucination but she was
frightened she'd lived 95 years and
she'd never had a hallucination before
she said that the hallucinations were
unrelated to anything she was thinking
or feeling or doing that they seemed to
come on by themselves or disappear she
had no control over them she said she
didn't recognize any of the people or
places in the hallucinations and none of
the people of the animals well they all
seemed oblivious of her and she didn't
know what was going on she wondered if
she was going mad or losing her mind
well I examined her carefully she was a
bright old lady perfectly sane she had
no medical problems she wasn't on any
medications which could produce
hallucinations but she was blind and I
then said to her I think I know what you
have I said there is a special form of
visual hallucination which may go with
deteriorating vision or blindness this
was originally described I said right
back in the 18th century by a man called
Charles bonny and you have Charles
Bonnie syndrome there's nothing wrong
with your brain there's nothing wrong
with your mind you have Charles Bonet
syndrome and she was very relieved at
this that was nothing seriously the
matter and also rather curious she said
um who is the shuls Bonnie she said did
he have them himself and she said um
tell all the nurses that I have Charles
bonnet syndrome
not crazy I'm not demented I have
Charles bonnet syndrome
well so I did tell the nurses now this
for me is a common situation I work on
old-age homes largely I see a lot of
elderly people who are hearing impaired
or visually impaired about 10% of the
hearing impaired people get musical
hallucinations and about 10% are the
visually impaired people get visual
hallucinations you don't have to be
completely blind only sufficiently
impaired
now with the original description and
the 18th century Charles bonny did not
have them his grandfather had these
hallucinations his grandfather was a
magistrate and elderly man he'd had
cataract surgery his vision was pretty
poor and in 1759 he described to his
grandson various things he was seeing
the first thing he said was he saw a
handkerchief in midair it was a large
blue handkerchief with four orange
circles and he knew it was a
hallucination you don't have
handkerchiefs in midair and then he saw
a big wheel in midair but sometimes he
wasn't sure whether he was hallucinating
or not because the hallucinations would
fit in the context of the visions so on
one occasion when his granddaughter's
were visiting them he said and who were
these handsome young men with you and
they said alas Grampa par there are no
handsome young men and then the handsome
young men disappeared it's some typical
of these hallucinations that they may
come and a flash and disappear the flesh
they don't usually fade in and out
they're rather sudden and they change
suddenly
Charles Lulla the grandfather saw
hundreds of different figures in
different landscapes of all sorts on one
occasion he saw a man and a bathrobe
smoking a pipe and realized it was
himself that was the only figure he
recognized on one occasion when he was
walking the streets of Paris he saw this
was real
yeah folding but when he got back home
he saw a miniature of the scaffold and
six inches high on his study table this
repetition of perception are sometimes
called Pavan op SIA well with him and
with Rosalie what seems to be going on
and mostly said what's going on and I
said that as you lose vision as the
visual parts of the brain are no longer
getting any input they become
hyperactive and excitable and they start
to fire spontaneously and you start to
see things the things you see can be
very complicated indeed with a another
patient of mine who also had some vision
the vision she had could be disturbing
on one occasion she said she saw a man
in a striped shirt and a restaurant and
he turned round and then he divided into
six figures and striped shirts who
started walking towards her
and then the six figures came together
like a concertina once when she was
driving or rather her husband was
driving the road divided into four and
she felt herself going simultaneously up
four roads
she had very young mobile hallucinations
as well a lot of them had to do with a
car sometimes she would see a teenage
boy sitting on the hood of the car he
was very tenacious and he moved rather
gracefully when when the car turned and
then when they came to a stop the boy
would do a sudden vertical takeoff 100
foot in the air and then disappear
another patient of mine had a different
sort of hallucination this was a woman
who didn't have trouble with her eyes
but the visual parts of her brain and
the tumor in the occipital cortex and
above all she would see cartoons and
these cartoons would be transparent and
would cover half of the visual field
like a screen and especially she saw
cartoons
of Kermit the Frog
now um I don't watch Sesame Street but
she made a point of saying why Kermit
she said Kermit the Frog means nothing
to me you know I mean I was wondering
about Freudian determinants why why
Kermit Kermit the Frog means nothing to
me she didn't mind the cartoons too much
but what did disturb her was she got
very persistent images or hallucinations
of faces and as with Rosa Lee the faces
were often deformed with very large
teeth or very large eyes and and these
fighting huh well what is going on with
these people as a physician I have to
try and define what's going on and to
reassure people especially to reassure
them that they're not going insane
something like 10 percents as I said of
impaired visually impaired people get
these but no more than 1% of the people
acknowledge them because they're afraid
they will be seen as insane or something
and if they do mention them to their own
doctors they may be misdiagnosed in
particular the notion is that if you see
things or hear things you're going mad
but the psychotic hallucinations are
quite different
psychotic hallucinations whether they're
visual or vocal they address you they
accuse you they seduce you they
humiliate you they gear at you you
interact with them there is none of this
quality of being addressed with these
Charles bonnet hallucinations there is a
film you've gone until you're seeing a
film which had nothing to do with you or
that's our people think about it there's
also a rare thing called temporal lobe
epilepsy and sometimes if one has this
one may feel oneself transported back to
a time and place in the past
you ought a particular road junctions
you smell chestnuts roasting you hear
the traffic all the senses were involved
and you're waiting for your girl and as
that Tuesday evening back in 1982 and
the temporal lobe hallucinations are all
sent SaLuSa nations full of feeling full
of familiarity located in space and time
coherent dramatic the shelves bony ones
are quite different so in the these
shelves bony hallucinations you have all
sorts of level from the geometrical
hallucinations the pink and blue squares
the woman had up to quite elaborate
hallucinations with figures and
especially faces faces and sometimes
deformed faces of a single commonest
thing in these hallucinations and one of
the second common list is cartoons so
what is going on fascinatingly in the
last few years has been possible to do
functional brain image
do fMRI on people as they are
hallucinating and in fact to find that
different parts of the visual brain are
activated as they are hallucinating when
people have these simple geometrical
hallucinations the primary visual cortex
is activated this is the part of the
brain which perceives ages and patterns
you don't form images with your primary
visual cortex when images are formed a
higher part of the visual cortex is
involved in the temporal lobe and in
particular one area the temporal lobe is
called the fusiform gyrus and it's known
that if people have damage in the
fusiform gyrus they may lose the ability
to recognize faces but if there's an
abnormal activity in the fusiform gyrus
they may hallucinate faces and this is
exactly what you find in some of these
people there's an area in the anterior
part of this gyrus where teeth and eyes
are represented and that part of the jaw
is activated when people get the
deformed hallucinations there is another
part of the brain which is especially
activated when one sees cartoons
it's activated when one recognizes
cartoons when one duels cartoon so when
one hallucinates them it's it's very
interesting that that should be specific
there are other parts of the brain which
are specifically involved with a
recognition and hallucination of
buildings and landscapes and around 1970
it was found that there were not only
parts of the brain but particular cells
face cells were discovered around 1970
and now we know that there hundreds of
other sorts of cells which can be very
very specific so you may not only have
car cells you may have them aasta.martin
cells i saw an aston martin this morning
i had to bring it and and and now it
sits in there somewhere so now at this
level in what's called the info temporal
cortex there are only visual images of
figments of fragments it's only at
higher levels that the other sensors
join in and their connections with
memory and emotion and in the Charles
bonnet syndrome
you don't go to those higher levels
you're on these levels of inferior
visual cortex where you have thousands
and tens of thousands and millions of
images or figments of Hagman who
figments all newly encoded in particular
cells or small clusters of cells
normally these are all part of the
integrated stream of perception or
imagination and one is not conscious of
them it is only if one is visually
impaired or blind that the process is
interrupted and instead of getting
normal perception you are getting an
anarchic convulsive stimulation or
release of all of these visual cells in
the info temporal cortex so suddenly you
see a face suddenly you see a car
suddenly this and suddenly that the mind
does its best to organize and to give
some sort of coherence to this but not
terribly
successfully when these were first
described it was thought that they could
be interpreted like dreams but in fact
people say I don't recognize the people
I can't form any associations permit
means nothing to me you don't get
anywhere thinking of them as dreams well
I'm more or less said what I wanted I
think just um I just want to
recapitulate and say this is common
think of the number of blind people must
be hundreds of thousands of live people
who had these hallucinations but are too
scared to mention them so this sort of
thing needs to be brought into into
notice for patients for doctors for the
public finally I think they are
infinitely interesting and valuable for
giving one some insight as to how the
brain works
Charles Bonet said 250 years ago he
wondered how the thinking of these
hallucinations how is he put at the
theater of the mind could be generated
by the machinery of the brain now 250
years later I think we're beginning to
glimpse how this is done thanks very
much
[Applause]
speak about these things with so much
insight and empathy your patience I mean
have you yourself experienced I mean the
syndromes you write about I was afraid
you would ask that well yeah a lot of
them and actually I'm a little visually
impaired myself I'm blind and one I am
not terribly good in the other and I I
see the geometrical hallucinations but
they stop there and they don't disturb
you you because you understand what's
doing it where they don't disturb me
anymore than my tinnitus which which at
which I ignore and they occasionally
interest me and I have many pictures of
them in my notebooks I've got an had an
fMRI myself to see how my visual cortex
is taking over and and when I see all
these hexagons and complex things which
I also have in visual migraine I I
wonder whether everyone sees things like
this and whether things like cave art or
ornamental art may have been derived
from them a bit that was an utterly
utterly fascinating talk thank you so
much for sharing prepared thank you